250 stagiaires formés l'an passé
cinquante intervenants pour une
quinzaine de formations métiers le
nouveau centre ifo coop est implantée à
montigny le bretonneux depuis septembre
2015 avec pour objectif un retour à
l'emploi rapide et pour y parvenir une
seule formule magique 50% du temps en
entreprise 50% en formation le format
des formations ifo cops et quatre mois
en centre de formation est une
application concrète de quatre mois en
entreprise
ça fait partie du cursus de chercher et
de trouver son entreprise nous
l'objectif ce n'est pas une formation
pour un stage c'est une formation pour
un emploi web digital gestion ressources
humaines ou encore comptabilité le choix
de formation est conséquent à saint
quentin en yvelines et répond aux
besoins des entreprises locales peu
importe l'âge ou les diplômes le plus
important se trouve ailleurs pour les
intéressés les plus jeunes auront 21 22
ans il est indispensable pour entrer à
l'ifop d'avoir au moins un an
d'expérience professionnelle ça c'est
vraiment le préalable indispensable pour
tout le monde
sur certains métiers on va demander une
expérience professionnelle poulon
préalable sur d'hôtel pour être plus
courte mais peut être compensée par un
niveau bac un niveau bac +2 en fonction
des qualifications requises a dit qu à
l'issue de la formation ce qui est
récurrent chez toutes les personnes
encore une fois c'est vraiment la
motivation la détermination le projet
professionnel et l'adéquation avec le
marché du travail de son en l'espace
d'un an plus de 200 inscrits à l'ifocop
de saint quentin en yvelines ont
retrouvé un emploi un chiffre qui
pourrait être amplifiée avec le plan
500000 formations supplémentaires mises
en place par le gouvernement